123 jetzt läuft schon center seien
herzlich willkommen
wir sind gerade in frankfurt gestern
waren wir in duisburg und dann noch
investor und die oft vorher
ich weiß gar nicht mehr wo wir überall
waren jedenfalls wollte ich euch mit
diesem video sagen dass wir jetzt eine
kurze auszeit machen wir machen den
fuchs also wir verschenken murat nicht
brennend durch mitsamt kindern uns
gepäck wir waren jetzt die letzten
wochen und monate wirklich sehr lang und
sehr oft unterwegs
wir kommen jetzt gerade vom web video
preis den wir gewonnen haben herzlichen
dank für eure unterstützung und für eure
ganzen glückwünsche
davor hatten wir zwei messen einmal in
dortmund einmal in wels da mittendrin
hat mir ein autogramm stunde
wir sind gerade mit dem bau beschäftigt
mit dem haus mit dem youtube videos mit
meinem buch mit autogrammstunden was
aber noch alles im vatikan aber noch
murat habe ich noch und jetzt haben wir
gedacht kommen sally morath jetzt ist es
an der zeit ein bisschen urlaub zu
machen
deswegen gehen wir jetzt für die
nächsten zehn tage mit ihrer kleinen
familie also hat samira und allein
urlaub werden einfach mal die seele
baumeln lassen
die wohnung von den schwiegereltern
genau in die türkei fliegen mir und
werden einfach mal uns ausruhen und wir
wollen in dieser zeit auch was wir
wollen wir möchten einfach dieses mal
versuchen keine kommentare zu
beantworten und das handy einfach mal
zur seite leben legen und wirklich ohne
internet auch ausgeben
meine videos werden trotzdem wir bieten
freitag sonntag veröffentlicht das heißt
die ganzen rezepte gibt es trotzdem für
euch die kommentar funktion bleibt noch
aktiv weil ich weiß dass ihr ganz tolle
zuschauer seit und bestimmt trotzdem
tolle kommentare schreiben werde
und ja also wundert euch nicht darüber
dass wir nichts antworten wie gesagt wir
machen jetzt einmal zehn tage pause
genau das brauchen wir einfach mal handy
abschalten einfach nur zeiten für den
kinder pflanzen gehen liebe kindern
abends mit ob mit der familie essen
gehen und da freuen wir uns auch
wirklich schon sehr drauf müssen jetzt
auch neue kraft tanken denn wir möchten
ja noch das buch
ich machen und möchten noch weitere
videos drehen ich brauche wieder ein
paar ideen das heißt wird auch eine
kleine kulinarische reise weil wir
abends einfach keine restaurants mal
schauen was da alles passiert jetzt aber
auf jeden fall unser auto gefragt wann
es zum flughafen rüber und dann zehn
tage weg und wir wünschen euch eine
schöne zeit vor allem mit ängsten schöne
ramadan zahlt und verbringt auch genau
ist nur reden jetzt richtig so
face to face einfach sagen dass ich
nicht 100 das ist keine kommentare von
uns zurück kommen
aber falls natürlich dringende fragen
habt im shop oder so dann sind natürlich
unsere unser team ist trotzdem da
scharen kabine und mein restliches team
die werden euch die fragen auch
beantworten und sind für euch da und
sagen tschüss sagen wir gehen jetzt
müssen auch hierbleiben und danke
[Musik]
am 8